taco bell got rid of a lot of menu items
oh yeah all right what's going on with
that why did they do that
unless a lot of people talk about this
what did they get rid of
well here's the list there it is all
this the seven-layer burrito
supremes are gone this happened in
august but they recently have been there
a while
they're getting rid of the mexican pizza
now and that's going to go away in
november and that was that
was my favorite thing it's like me too i
love you mexican
dude if you want to [ __ ] your pants
order mexican pizza
so good though do you know why they're
getting rid of it what's the crunchyroll
supreme though that's still let's see
they still doing stuff with the dorito
shell yep yeah i love those oh i heard
those are going to go anywhere too
okay what they say about the mexican
pizza the boxes the boxes are taking too
much you know it's too much trash
all the all the the paper the paper for
the boxes
yeah it's not good environments make
them out of a different material maybe
yeah what about a different material
i don't know that's the real soft taco
okay similar burrito
not supreme one of my faves i like those
uh i like those
the spicy potatoes no don't care cheesy
fest potatoes
staple um i'm not familiar
familiar with the loaded griller it is
the cheesy potato loaded
griller is top notch i never had that
i'm
nacho supreme are you [ __ ] chips and
pico de gallo
yeah they get rid of pico de gallo but
can i still get the chips and the nacho
cheese
that's wild i'm sure you could because
cheese is very important
wow as long as i got crunchwrap supremes
though yeah
do you pretty healthy how you [ __ ]
uh i don't eat fast food as much
but i do like it does your kid eat
healthy
yeah he does pretty well he eats
everything yeah so has he had
food though uh like mickey do you know
we've had chick-fil-a i've never taken
him to mcdonald's
i know i just i don't know i've never
been
i know but it's just so i'd rather take
them to chick-fil-a
teach its own i got him a ceiling fan
for his birthday too
doritos cool ranch and fiery doritos
those are gonna be gone
wow wow unreal man oh [ __ ] the grilled
stuffed burrito
double decker taco god i love the double
decker are you kidding you're [ __ ]
me
that was it [ __ ] that was so strong
dude [ __ ] out man i'm a del taco guy
now
the double decker is my favorite thing
how do you get rid of all i get
who is in that board meeting oh yeah
that guy should be [ __ ] fired
immediately
who said double decker get the [ __ ] out
now because here's the thing
you got the soft taco you got the
crunchy taco you got the supplies
sandwich them together dude [ __ ] you
taco bell how about that man
no i lost my business you lost my
business don't say it
yeah actually we could maybe use their
sponsorship so taco bell hey whatever
you guys think is is appropriate
i'm out man crunchwrap supreme bring
back the double or i'm
that doesn't even make sense then so
these are the new combos
and they have a mexican pizza here too
yeah what i don't know what's going on
misinformation oh they rank these are
ranked oh they're ranked
new combos
anyhow i like a chicken quesadilla man
oh they're chicken quesadillas so good
with a jalapeno sauce it's so good
taco bell is really good
right here
[Applause]
the fourth meal was huge fourth meal
yeah i'm more of a del taco fan though i
like their uh
uh hot sauce better their cheeseburger
double double
cheeseburger their cheeseburger is fire
and everyone's like so good everybody
gives
yeah you're going to get a hard time
here too what dude
yeah dude hey you got a you got a
deal are you go to delta and order a
burger i know
have you ever had it it's really good
i'm not cause i only like the
i only like the soft chicken tacos those
are good too
really good mouth is water and fat yeah
try both of them
yeah i'm going to do that well guys we
love you
i'm going to taco bell same thing
and before they take away all those
things oh november
we have until november yeah november 5th
or night oh we can go on halloween and
celebrate
oh how about that when i get off stage
at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son